from screen junkies studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fight now your host Andy signor oh
hello I'm AM iam so happy to be back
here on movie fights with three of my
favorite fighters let's do this it's
going to have some awesome battles
including what franchise would you like
to see incorporate time travel we also
have best Daniel day-lewis performance
and honor of him retiring from acting
what and we were going to talk about who
was going to direct new Star Wars but
that news was broken today that Ron
Howard is doing it so we want to go a
little broader in star wars in trouble
how would you fix it we're going to talk
about it so much more let's introduce
the fighters here to my left I'm so
happy to have them back the founder of I
mockery and no stranger to movie fights
welcome back mr. Roger bar a long time
you've grown a lot of hair better way
for many years and how many years has it
been
I seem to remember it was the year of
our Lord it was in October on the show
called movie function thank you for
having me back on here was a smoky time
but I'm sure we're going to have some
fun today and we will be better and even
longer
I'm looking forward to this match of
pinochle it'll be quite rude Oh adorable
I love you Roger I'm so glad to have you
back I'm reading long this beard already
wonder gee can we cut back it'll be gone
next up I she's the host of FX movie
download and it can be seen all over
screen JT news Sasha programmer welcome
back to Sasha how jet-lagged are you
yeah I do it I was in New Zealand I'm
wearing I met some awesome people a Weda
I promised I'd wear the shirt featuring
travel there by ship I did the very
launch in London New Zealand I saw so
many awesome fans out there thank you
guys so much but yes I'm still sort of
thank you Dan we'll get there before I
get to thank Dan Sasha yeah thanks for
being here I'm very excited I'm super
excited because I was getting d-ends
last night already an idea
I will get some air Roger games last
time we run out it was the movie games
and I'm great and I love J and in James
just like that yeah he's really hands on
Twitter let's get to him right eye and
now you seem all over news and all over
the web and I guess he's blowing up
jaywalking tell you I'm having to be
here I'm not going to see really what
keeps freaking oppressing our old I got
these power buttocks and they pushing
this here now
yeah positive I love you to death with
sweet on I love you but uh you won the
last time we fought looking here I don't
care you know you're responsible you can
argue against a spike Lee joint that was
just like ah and also here and you put
the wonderful sauce programmer hand this
to us know what your blows up your
Oakland before it has none of characters
to me wondering why is everyone yelling
no they would not player I was calling
myself it
I didn't like this gentleman cuz it's
been a while I know I know but I left
the beginning but I'll and be recognized
by than I oh I got I got I also hear it
way back in the day and stuff and I'm
alright that feels so good
alright well I wanna get to the fight
but I gotta take articulate the back
checker and last week's amazing judge oh
thank you mr. Dan Merle Dan we were so
good they all want me fired
oh come on I can't do I can never do if
you sat here long enough they turn on
you too the only non fun part of the
show is judging because two-thirds of
the audience will always disagree with
what you have to say so no I did a great
job in your great fight and thank you
for stepping in enough sir I love dude
you would be judging the show if you
weren't the best fighter I need to see
you fight all the time people forget and
your battles coming up soon and it's
update yet no we're going to know that
waiter yeah I know I got you and Mike
Carlson it's going to get getting a crew
veto Amato will we'll announce it next
week the date I think those are just two
of them no one
I've been so out of it I don't know
what's going on here won't get you back
in here you're still champ well done you
for now see um so I'm excited to see how
that battle goes now I'm excited to have
you here to help me today and I'm
excited to do this any questions guys
you know how this works right yes I
think I remember yes I hope so and if
you're watching live in the conversation
we are live with Twitter hashtag movie
fights live yes Dan that's correct
movie fights live on Twitter I am ready
and willing a lot of people thing they
can watch yeah exit technology alright
let's do it
what a lovely night why'd you turn that
down fight
well I'm so good so good keeping that
one for a while because a fan made it
hairy man you crushed it round one
all right this is funny because I was so
confused by transformers last night but
this question was supposed to be
connected to it I said it was such a
cool question you like to gave to school
ko answers that we kept it but I thought
last night was all about like time
travel apparently not so it's not so it
was nothing to do thank you question so
my hound answers should not be shows so
it says no she was reinforces that hence
widest questions here just to clarify
became an idea thank you for taking
London Lane oh my god I anyway I thought
it was and I thought this question was
fine your answers were fun that we kept
it anyway so the question is what movie
your character what movie character or
franchise do you want to enter core
incorporate time travel in a sequel that
hasn't already it's a what movie I just
watched I'm cop again in a plane that
meets junghwa it's not a perfect movie
but it's really fun but they could do it
again better sure but let's see what
were you guys gonna pick what's the
movie that hasn't done time travel that
you'd love to see a character do you
incorporate time travel roger bar you're
back in it let's hear it alright my
choice is Friday the 13th big shocker
I'm short Jason Voorhees has been to
camp he's been to Manhattan he's been to
space and he's even been to Hell where
else can you send him but back to the
past or way farther in the future where
ever you want to send him he's going to
have the way more people to kill
basically I don't want to see I want to
see Jason like go back to the 50s and
hack up students like at a rock and roll
thing I'd love to see him go away into
the future maybe like demolition man and
kill someone just as they're about to
use the three seashells and we still
don't get to find out how they're used
that sort of thing so yeah I'd love you
to be damned goop it out the shells yeah
they say you grant you use two of them
to pull some out and then the final
shell yeah we don't need to shred that
anyway Sasha you're next
I mean there really seems like there's
only one answer to this and that is the
Vezina furious I mean we've gone a Tokyo
we've gone to Dubai
we've gone to London let's go to the
future feet about this you already have
all the makings so you go way over 88
miles per hour when they're in those
cars you need to knock and it's just
like when you're in Star Wars sudden you
hit warp speed and you're hyper driving
into the future and suddenly you've got
not just cars but you've got all new
super futuristic vehicles that Ben has
to get his hands on so we can make them
the monster truck between that and the
future and it would be radical and also
that way when you have sort of like a
hologram version of Paul Walker it's not
weird okay yeah but now I see that when
I went outside weird no way where are
you taking us in the time travel I have
picked a franchise that almost died off
because they switched the main character
so I would bring this back with the
original character and I'm talking about
the transporter with Jason Statham okay
to have Frank Martin the former ex
British British operative he drives fast
and all of a sudden he has these pretty
personal rules okay the rule number one
don't change the deal
number two no names rule number three
never opened the package and that always
is what gets him in trouble
Rule three he opens the package in the
film and now said he's carrying all his
high-grade equipment of course he's
doing all the speeds and all the chases
sort of like fast furious and we'll get
to yours later but this one causes him
to take a jump in the time okay because
now he has some now he doesn't realize
where he is he's in the 50s and 60s
what's a black suit on he doesn't know
what he's dealing with all of a sudden
now he has an exotic love interest
because Jason Statham always has to have
an exotic love interest in these films
okay now you put this movie with this
guy trying to figure out how to get back
to his time while also dealing with
things
in that time whether they be the 50s 60s
and 70s you also going to incorporate
the big fight scene we always have the
first one in the first transporter when
he was fighting the bus depot under all
the oil the second where he was on the
boatyard
different things like that so I would
like to see the transporter well right
so on
but you're taking about fifties and
sixties you said yeah you're going on
the future Sasha and Roger you're on all
over the place yeah okay I'll explain
that you send your first one of its
first rules is not to change anything
you're already sending them you know
that's the deal not not good so you want
to have yours already Jason hey this is
whole chronic ecology has dealt with him
being in past the initial initial Friday
13 starts roughly seventies eighties we
watch him go through time already
yeah Jason X in space is basically a
flash forward to the future so basically
they've already done that they've
already done everything frozen he that's
not a highness a flash forward to the
future in a sense they put him under two
years ahead when it comes to the bass in
the Furious how much damn family got
busy no need okay a.m. he was like you
took my answer so you can't be LDS was I
the franchise was ruining coming anyway
I know the first was the only successful
transfer movie and I loved it first time
the second one was a disaster the third
one was a mess and it's a Ford one then
they brought in the other full so it had
already gone off the rails and was
completely downhill and a ram it has
been a furious is a perfect franchise
wise move on by the department I might
have been here a faceted we reason about
the best in the period laughing guys
yeah actually a movie people still go
and see Friday the 13th people only
watch undies oh no no I want to go out
the people behind why not Friday 13th
such as an hour
his whole lineage is Bentall time cares
about that because you can go back in
time and watch the originals and you can
be in the 80s you can go forward and
watch him in space and you're in the
future already does that it's not as
original okay great now why not fast and
furious you guys first off fast and
furious hasn't gone into time yet it may
be even gone into space yet so that
that's clearly the next logical thing
there guess is they're going to die
right they're going to hate life they're
going to duct-tape a car to a spaceship
and then hopefully the only thing you
want to do with time travel is there a
speaker essence of the best of the
Furious franchise
one I want to do with it I know
everybody wins no ways everybody won't
over Ludacris and the rock and bring
diesel drive off the Hubble telescope I
did it we would have to do that in the
future because we are not you're helping
here no no I'm sure Danny please okay I
don't want to see but again if there's
going to be a good movie no because we
keep getting Tyrese in these movies
however with the tri-carrier you're
probably the only one you're probably
the only one and when it comes to the
transporter again you want to put frame
art into different situations and
Aristotle M suck you want to put Frank
Martin into different situations and
different scenarios in different
cultures again to put Frank Martin in
the 50s and the 60s would be great a
bridge Dube just walking around the
fifties or sixties having zero idea
what's going on but trying to figure out
how to take these older cars not newer
cars older cars and modify the month for
him to be able to do this group so he is
blind you're talking about a British guy
walking around with an interracial we're
not saying that he's - we're not doing
it is not in this fun that's like Martin
Freeman is a military officer there is a
different Martin and if people remember
his name people never a bigot are
important territories karate not
transporter guys the transporter no one
no one no one cares about the transport
anymore it was already on his last limbs
after part two they they clearly had no
energy left in it you can tell like just
by the stunt work and stuff they weren't
doing anything with the series at that
point they're just phoning it in cashing
a paycheck because it was kind of a name
and stuff but that's the reason we don't
have any more transporter films now so
it just no one cares anymore that's it
now max is that okay so go around in
your last cell in Y years is the best
pitch okay
okay the transporter would have stayed
alone with Jason Statham ethics they
state-to-state end quote it was obvious
was a great experience doing those films
and I would have loved to keep doing it
but they wanted me to signed on and
three more films without even seeing a
script they offered me less money than
three that I got paid for one so as a
business decision
now with the success of Jason Statham
has had in other films of course you can
bring him back in for more money which
will rejuvenate the franchise you can
eliminate the transporter for the reloj
to rehash whichever one it was and now
take that further step up into the new
millennium with this franchise
Sasha found thoughts why fast McGarrett
I mean Jason Statham you already said it
you mean other franchises like The Fast
and Furious we've see
go through buildings we've seen them go
out of planes the only thing that is
left to do is take them into the future
you have to bring them into a new
millennium a new age because they are
already so advanced technologically and
the one thing that is always universal
is family the message of the movie will
still say solid the action set pieces
which are the reason to see Fast and
Furious movies will get even bigger even
more dynamic they have already created a
universe where the laws of physics don't
apply I want to see that in a futuristic
setting it's Blade Runner it's Star Wars
it's fast and furious it's Dec I think
Roger is not going to be Blade Runner
final [ __ ] no that is not going to be
Blade Runner not even remotely like it
for Friday the 13th I will make my case
here first up there there hung up on the
late 70s and 80s I'm not just saying
he's going to go back there he's going
to go back to 50s I want to see Jason go
back to medieval times let's see Jason
show these people like what real torture
looks like also slasher movies are due
for a big comeback we've had the zombies
in the ghost stories for quite a while
now slasher movies everyone has been
clamoring for them and it's going to
happen but the platform iMovie I already
worked it out it's simple Jason has
killed everybody in the world he has
nobody left he has nobody left to kill
and the one last person who he was he
killed at the end of the movie is a
scientist who was developing a time
machine a scientist who was developing a
time machine in hopes of going back in
time and erase in all of Jason's kills
but now jason has the time machine he
gets to travel to any time he wants and
kill everybody so that is my friend
Randy and a bubble moment and the name
also the name is Friday 13th back to the
future there you go what just what all
right Dan yes
thoughts there a couple things Sasha I
might recommend alarm went off when you
said they would blast off the warp speed
in Star Wars yeah that's okay I the only
thing a few people on Twitter also
pointed out while Jason X does take
place in the future
24:55 time travel itself is not
necessarily involved he was crazy not
frozen and then
time progress a lot of people with some
suggestions from Twitter Spencer and
fast day 17 says when stones we need a
live-action version of them meeting the
Jetsons
Ali Nelson says Jurassic Park to the
Past with real dinos Ryan Craig
Transformers pulling a day of Future
past would help the franchise no boy
James Bond franchise Daniel Craig's Bond
time travels and teams the Fatima thick
Dalton's bond label you know we also
have the Twitter poll Andy which I will
share with you actually make you rule
this almost tough actually a little bit
but then look what there was
they kind of dinged you in jail ed the
fart that's the fight on that which was
just that whether it was time to
everyone not we've seen Jason through a
lot of periods just because he's been
around so long so I thought that was a
really good punch and they came down to
fast and furious versus transporter and
all your stuff you were fighting against
him Sasha almost sounded like what's
wrong with that it's sounding like it's
Blake bond because that was your sort of
criticism it sounds like James Bond like
yeah those are great way yeah I mean I
really lost mine white so there's
holographic Paul Walker it's like
Jayde's pitch were you did take him back
and had to modify the old cars you just
sold me on a franchise I wouldn't care
about and I think you made a point of
the fact that he checked out with the
salary you bring them back with the
right idea and this could and Jubilate
the franchise a bit I got to give J the
first point you're on the board when
they say the motorpool voted as the
majority 54 well just about 50% voted
for fast in the Furious 37% for Friday
13th only 13% of the online forum a man
back back baby here we go round two
alright so we were asked who should
direct the new Star Wars han solo solo
movie see it's fellow movie but they
just announced this Ron Howard am i
right today officially knows
regards ours I know is rumored this
morning but they didn't finally I know
it because I've seen a million Arrested
Development jokes yes it was announced
exactly yep
but we want to ask you know look this is
this is a big news story this is a big
thing to pull a director out directors
out that long in the production there's
also now talk of a counter Varro's new
film isn't wonderful right Dan's I hear
that correctly
come on tomorrow's new film the book
portrays that making people very excited
about Episode eight or nine it's insane
you'll be talking more about that
exactly
thanks for dance reviewing that because
it's down hilarious we're so yeah for
some guy anyway so people are starting
to wonder if Star Wars in trouble could
it be in trouble we want you guys in a
scale of one to ten meaning one it's all
good to ten all panic tell us is it in
trouble and how do we fix it who do you
bring in this little cuckoo would you
brought in what can you do to sort of
save this franchise and save it but you
know like steer it in a place that's
gonna get us all comfortable or are we
going crazy and they're doing fine
Sasha you're first tell us what do you
think okay so I think we are directly to
five I think that if we were talking
about is what does this mean for
filmmaking it would be a nine because I
think pulling directors off three and a
half weeks before filming set to wrap is
a major disaster doing it now I think
that what we're seeing is directing by
studio more than we've ever seen it the
way I think we fix this is we now know
that Marvel DC and Star Wars are
completely overseen by a head honcho we
are taking away the individuality of the
director and that bums me out because I
love Lord Miller but I think their
samples still very much beyond this Han
Solo movie I think the way that we fix
it something forward is when Kevin Feige
leaves Marvel he takes over Star Wars
and that's how we're okay that's my
pitch so you're just taking Feige from
one Disney property the neck I think in
2019 we will see him leave Marvel and I
think he will slide over to Star Wars
and I think that that will be the voice
that is the instead of the Kathleen
Kennedy who I love but I think she has a
very old-school take and Lawrence Kasdan
is really intense about this is my
vision and this is my baby and I want my
words to be my words and I think they
should be open to new soft sand
possibilities and I think Kevin Feige is
an incredible about giving directors who
are slightly
les tested the platform to do something
huge with executive oversight what I
think we have here is massive executive
oversight and that will lead to a sort
of pasteurization of the projects all
right Jay where are you staying on the
scale and what do you do to fix all
right so I initially took I don't think
it's in that much of an issue the reason
being - you're saying - right so it's
the lower end we heard about this with
the untimely situation with Zack Snyder
and his family where all of a sudden
Josh Queen had to step in and redo some
reshoots and finish up the film right
now if this is a record you trust which
everybody trusts in Ron Howard then
what's the problem
now going forward into college tomorrow
of course everybody saying the book of
Henry is horrible which our initial
questions were who would be your
director to handle that I pick James
Dunn because he knows space he knows
these characters he knows comedy he
knows the camaraderie he knows how to
put it on samba film together James got
to show he knows universe is also Kevin
Feige has given him assistant control of
the Marvel cosmic universe so he's going
to go further along in this Star Wars is
not in trouble this has been a franchise
that has been researched with the force
awakens
now many people may have different
feelings on a lot of people said well
the force awakens was just a new hope
again it might have been but guess what
there was a whole new Legion fans
40 years ago never saw a new hope or
just not caught up to it but then you
have the Clone Wars attacking all the
prequels and now you have this Han Solo
spin-off now you're giving people
backstories and the characters that some
people feel like you don't need but many
people actually do want
so is this franchise in trouble not at
all because now we have this bigger
thing it's not even franchises anymore
there's a word we've been using for the
past six months and it's called
universes I just used it twice and
describing with James Gunn this is a big
gigantic universe you put a director
like a James Gunn who knows this he has
experience with the aliens so when you
have all these different creatures
you're not just talking human elements
you're talking these out of worldly
elements the colors automatically with
Star Wars when they brought in when they
first did the Phantom Menace the new
visuals of that was so amazing people
were shocked because it didn't fall
along the lines with the original three
the Vigilant visually I said it was the
best thing I'm not saying it's the best
but it did some visually that was
different from the bridge because
everybody's like wait a minute the
original three
like this this looks like that James
Goethe's volume guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and was the first director to use
the 8k camera grant a lot of people's
eye were not ready for that color
spectrum yet but now imagine applying to
a theory of a universe like Star Wars I
don't want to wait some trouble all
right Roger what do you think wow that
is long UK my god
damn right it was alright well first off
I'm on the higher end of the spectrum I
I think this is a bad sign for the
quality of the films I don't think Star
Wars as a franchise itself will ever be
in trouble really I mean it it survived
the prequels essentially so the prequels
they can survive the numbering and my
number is around 7 or 8 I would say and
that's just directly about the quality
of these films I think Disney is really
excited they got this big franchise that
they purchased and now they're just like
let's get stuff out let's get stuff out
let's gets about but if if you just keep
churning stuff out over and over again
constantly you're going to have some
kind of dipping quality just because too
many hands in the cookie jar is that's
essentially the way I see it and this
this Han Solo movie I don't know if
anyone really ever wanted and I
certainly don't think it was necessary I
don't think we need it we already we
already know what happened the entirety
of Han Solo's story from the the first
Star Wars films up until what happened
to him in the reason I think we can
spoil that he's dead right oh yeah oh so
with Han Solo being dead I feel like
there's there's just there's no weight
to this at this point there's just not a
lot of weight behind it doing film but
if we're going to have a han Solo movie
as the question was last night that we
were all asked before Ron Howard was
revealed to be the director what
director would we want to come in and
save it and to me it's George Miller
this is a director with incredible
incredible action in all of his scenes
when you see what he has done with the
Mad Max films and it's yet he's not a
space film's director but Han Solo is
more of a gritty character like you'd
see in the Mad Max film and that's kind
of why George Miller is like the perfect
thing han Solo and Mad Max have a lot of
similarities you know they're kind of
entering these crazy
situations that isn't like their main
story but they're still having to deal
with the consequences of it and all so
that's where I see a lot of similarities
between the two and that gritty universe
that George Miller can create I think it
works perfect so I think that would be
wonderful for her Han Solo to see him
you know all right who thinks three
others are crazy here oh I mean this
one's out of his mind for DNA if you're
listening right you're talking about
James Gunn knowing comedy the reason
that Lord Miller were ripped off of the
movie is because there was too much
comedy and there was too much
improvisation which are the Keystone's
of James Gunn so automatically you are
setting them up to fail in the exact
same way that the studio already felt
that they were failing I appreciate the
idea George Miller because I think
George Miller visually would be awesome
and you're right he does do action but
he does action action action action
action if you want to bring in a
director who would be interesting I
think you either give it to Donald
Glover who was already playing Lando
Calrissian that would be rad and he's
done so much with Atlanta or you give it
to Shane black Shane black who
understands camp comedy and action but
the problem that we have here is neither
of you guys are actually I really
appreciate what you're saying about
universes and also what you're saying
about these are big universes and that's
how we're describing them but the thing
is is with the universe you shouldn't
have the exact same monotone idea
everything should be interesting and I
did want to come to Los Angeles and
that's that's why I want George Miller
to do it because he won't do the exact
same thing and I really worry about
Disney making Hansell almost too jokey
and I could see James Gunn doing that
easily I could see him turning I could
start seeing turning Han Solo into Star
Wolf star-lord but that's a hospital
care to watch no no it's a joke I
thought oh you know who has some is more
so than Mad Max absolutely is basically
the star-lord type of character is my
fellow the Han Solo we love is the Han
Solo who when he's told I love you he
goes honey now that is not star-lord
that is your car Lord I'm talking about
now we're going before against will
alert before he died again we got bored
with the older Harrison Ford and again
you're going into a spin-off to show how
he was again when he has the the car the
game with Lando Calrissian and he wins
the Millennium Falcon there's going to
be jokes and gags in there not to say
that the whole movie is improvisation
Jan blunt also knows how to follow the
line of a scrip of what you want for
your universe Kevin Feige told him
listen I need you to take these
characters that are relatively unknown
which are now known and make them go
into this plan again guardians of the
galaxy one was just about the story of
the offending zone
oh dear a person to take over I'm not
saying I'm not bringing it up I just
know I'm not like that's the point
that's not the point I'm bringing it all
here's what you want me to say I won't
say it away when you're talking you're
saying that you said we don't need these
different things you said we just let it
be and I believe that was Roger all
right and we need we need it to change
as much as possible right sandwich the
cabinet all we should have these
different banks again no matter how
people who are in the TV and film
industry to review and critically say
the audience's are going to see these
different things again people are going
to see ro1 people have what the bureau
should for attack of the Cold War's
people are going to see these Star Wars
products that are being put out so why
is it how is there trouble when there is
an audience that is constantly going to
see them when world one came out no
matter how much people may have send a
dislike it the number said otherwise the
problem is the other final go ahead the
final thought the problem isn't how much
money it's going to make the problem is
is how good will the movie be and I
think that one of the things that we've
seen Marvel do so well under Kevin Feige
is we get somebody like the Russo
brothers who we've done television and
something it's like make this gigantic
movie I think what we need is we need
more original thought even in a universe
that is well established and my fear
with what we're seeing Florida Miller is
they are very much iconoclastic and by
having
Kasdan and Kennedy come in and take
things over and give it to somebody
who's so old-school like Ron Howard
who's the director I love flashes when
they favor movies ever I that is what
concerns me because you are muting a
voice it should be heard Roger fan
thoughts okay well I I agree if we're
having a han Solo movie we want original
thought and George Miller will deliver
that the the latest Mad Max fury road
was more original than any pretty much
any action film we've seen in ages I
mean that's why everyone left exhausted
after watching because it was just
non-stop and it was incredible
experience but one of the things I think
everyone would expect to see in a han
Solo movie if we're going to see a han
Solo prequel about is his old story we
want to see how Han Solo did the
the Kessel run in 12 parsecs well that's
clearly some kind of crazy speed race
and that's going to be one of the
highlights of the entire film so who
else is going to do a high-speed
adventure like that better than George
Miller nobody and on top of that George
Miller is is he's great with the
practical effects and blending them with
the actual the CGI so it's going to look
wonderful just like it did in Mad Max
and a lot of the leaked photos and stuff
from the Han Solo movie shows a lot of
the vehicles and it looks something like
straight out of Mad Max there's articles
online that say that very thing so I
could totally see George Miller pulling
this off damn well putting aside the
fact that parsec is a measure distance
not trying Han Solo would tell you that
he did the council room in less than 12
parsecs that was the only you know this
is an opinion round so not a whole lot
actually the correct a lot of very
opinionated people on Twitter though JJ
582 says Star Wars is fine they can do
whatever they want if people go see it
the movies will never fail and I'm not
even a fan jack mayor says the problem
is George Miller would want to make a
big r-rated spectacle but Kathleen
Kennedy we want to keep it pg-13 Langley
nearly says the only reason anyone was
interested in the solo is because of
Lord and Miller so he ought to think
there's a bit of trouble there Brian
Knight says Lucasfilm slow down in the
sight of their they'll make your
friendly or a strict universe both they
have to figure it out so the lines of
opinion on Twitter about this topic yeah
we have the whole discussion I think
they look good some good stuff said by
everybody but I heard some really the
strongest stuff out of Sasha I mean you
sort of play the middle but you did I
like that you also sort of citable to
9/4 filmmakers because your whole thing
there about the filmmakers by studio and
the not visionary I think that's that
spoke the truest I think for the for the
saves bat but still there is a struggle
there because Jay and Yerger me said
people are going to see movie what's the
trouble
that is a I think a pair of trouble
making sure the movies good and not just
spitting them out to spit them out
George Miller I think would be a good
choice but Kevin Feige was a little too
broad but then when you sort of pitched
me like the Donald Glover Shane black
sand and your point
that they could fit a little bit more
and listen to Kathleen Kennedy's stuff
while not muting the voice fully I think
that was just a really well thought out
thing so I got to get the other one even
though Donald's only done like two of us
every single way I don't like to
different doesn't matter nearly Kenny's
directing the movie yeah oh my god
someone made a Power Move there anyway
alright round three
guys did you know that Damon this comes
in from Jeff sorry I've been not retweet
this one came in from Chase Thompson bow
a chase tbh on Twitter
did you know Damon Lindelof is
developing a watchman television series
Wow
well why the question isn't it related
that I don't know I get what you did the
who watches that we want to ask though a
similar question what box-office
disappointment would you like to be
reimagined for television something that
we could take redo Westworld s - yeah
what one let's say Jair first speaking
of Westworld of the world's water world
the story of the Mariner played by Kevin
Costner who is living on the world and
now the polar ice caps have melted and
the whole big entire thing in this movie
is to find a little girl who supposedly
has a tattoo of coordinates on her back
to dry land this movie was a flop
because people were like no it doesn't
work how love it
this movie has spawned several different
audiences had a video game it's had a
novel it's had comic books this movie
now currently still has three rides in
three different amusement parks that is
still going so why not give this movie
yes this book is actually has that going
ton show which one is this gun show so
any different father would oppose okay
they say there was a reopening is
everyone all right
but nonetheless nonetheless but it had
all of those it had different options
from the film what this means is it
could go into television
now when you say television we're not
talking about broadcast television we're
not Samar cable you also have Netflix
now Netflix is shown you can do a season
in eight episodes in 13 episodes you
don't need the traditional 2223
my world has so many different
storylines it can go because just
because they found the dry land on top
of Mount Everest doesn't mean he can't
still travel the world because he did
leave off in the movie to travel the
world because his heart was in the sea
as Kevin Costner said which means he can
run into different elements in different
parts of in the four corners of the
earth so that is why I feel Waterworld
before now let's go Fawcett project
first Roger will be picking love you I'm
taking the Big Lebowski
I think the Lebowski just like Fargo
with the Coen brothers has blossomed
into such an incredible TV series
everyone should watch it if you haven't
already seen it it is just fantastic and
I hope it never ever thought right I
know really it's just incredible the
Lebowski it's another world we could
have so much fun and just I'll think of
all the quirky characters that he runs
into over the course of just that one
film and Fargo has demonstrated the
similar kind of thing so I would love to
see the dude just doing his thing and
something weird is with Jeff Bridges oh
absolutely yeah you can't you cannot
have the Big Lebowski without Jeff
Bridges okay great he is the dude we'll
hear more Sasha what are you picking so
I took a bunch more West worldly
approach to this which is I picked the
Cotton Club which in movie differences
for Coakley did with Richard Gere Diane
Lane it's not a great movie it's an okay
movie but what I thought was yeah you
give your you give your not grandson
what's the nephew your nephew you give
your nephew a thing and I will say
Gregory Hines is beyond amazing and I
love them so much but you have the
Cotton Club the famous club in Harlem in
the 1930s and we don't need any of the
original cast but what we do have is all
of the best parts of Boardwalk Empire
Treme and Luke Cage if you put Luke Cage
back in like the 1930s that's very much
what the Cotton Club is you have this
really interesting dynamic of racial
politics where you've got basically all
black performers and then all white
people who frequent the club you've got
gangs you've got musicians you've got
drug use you've got gun malls you've got
dancers trying to make it you've got the
guy who's getting involved with the
gangsters girl from but he's not
supposed to it's such a rich world it's
such a beautiful world it would be a
prestige piece for any network and in
terms of directors yeah you could ring
can Francis Ford Coppola back in to do
it you could also
launched a crazy new sort of like it's
not the right era but when I say Mad Men
go with me in terms of med men and
Downton Abbey were appointment
television on broadcast and part of that
was the incredible spectacle that they
brought every week and that's what the
Cotton Club could do plus you would have
insane music every single week and such
dope performers well right the it's
unfortunate you already mentioned
Boardwalk Empire those already existed
that of jebaited Italian planets they
had the Onyx club in Norwalk Empire and
often they would be troubling and
ignited a thriving Boardwalk Empire
grab that we are like in Somalia no but
you're in the club the entire time what
I'm saying you took one club out of the
entire scene to Luke Cage the Harlem
paradise is work we have everything
there I'm sorry Dick Tracy was one of my
other favorites and I almost with this
in that presentation not historically
one club
my notes are literally it was a crime
drama senator around a club that's
basically the plot of a Dick Tracy Tracy
taking drugs big boy and a sub R it is
basically recycling did I know right
that's my boy that whatever do I plot
but also we proven that post-apocalyptic
films and TV shows oh my god well I'm
here to Walking Dead and it shouldn't be
around but you know going around a war
again it is a Mad Max typesetting setup
oh and Ellen wash on water it's boring
or water we never survive it why would
bring a ass like it because we think
it's one set of malaya again the option
here we're not you want to know why you
want to know why Waterworld a lot of Big
Lebowski exam
alright alright first off we don't need
the water World Series because it's they
make it to land at the end of the movie
where you know what happens with that on
top of it
water world's budget was ridiculous and
to pull it off and to make it look easy
you need a huge budget these days and
they're not going to give Waterworld a
game of thrones budget that's just not
going to happen
it's Waterworld poison to Hollywood it
is poison and I'm sort of has been
article 20 2013 of seven dudes is a
trail
I'm sorry being back the balance of
inflation Waterworld should not be
considered one of the biggest losses
all-time we're in trouble 24 if you
don't have a deadline order honey do you
know this tequila for a billion dollar
John that's a ridiculous idea but back
to Waterworld when you say because of
the budget again we've shown that we
shall big spectacles of court game with
the heavens magnificent budget it does
not have to everything does not have to
water all water world is more poisonous
to Hollywood and Kevin Costner's urine
water that is that is what it is and I'm
very confident about think about what
they would do with water world these
days think about it we know they're not
going to make it ridiculous and goofy
and fun to see all the original movie
was fun there were some plenty of fun
elements to it but these days they're
going to tie it in with like global
warming and make it all this some
message about like you know how the
oceans are rising and all that and we
have balancing only baby why should you
have it aside again I just wanted it you
guys knows one dude by one has a
military for every week I don't want to
be reminded of the more solar news
everything every time I wanted can
actually say something about Big
Lebowski because that is a movie that I
absolutely adore but when he brought it
up your exact quote was in terms of
Fargo who would have thought huh unless
Noah Hawley comes in and works magic for
a fourth time
I think the Big Lebowski is one of those
projects that just shouldn't be touched
because it is perfect horizontal oh so
it's not the kind of club is a world
that can be look like there's a world
that came the world capital than any
other world that was a day without key
like how I love to dude I love to do it
for two hours but do I love to do it for
a hundred hours of television
I hope so Lily what what do you want to
know how much people love the dude they
put on a Lebowski Fest every year that
a year's rent on some of the most
obscure representative that we presented
absolutely we're also wanting larger
fish all they want all these fans want
is more Lebowski so while you may not
and that's totally fair if you don't
there is a huge fan base out there
who does it Colin clamoring that's what
I do they don't want to do it they would
start some of it and then you let
whoever wants to take over just like
what's going on with party men is that
Ron Howard coming in to direct the big
lebowski not going to have right didn't
because the reticle right now that's
probably the club close no Holly coming
the reason a lot of judge last final
strawberry again like I said initially
the reason I brought up Waterworld no
matter how any eye we said movie flops
we said flops again for a movie to have
a video game which was known for doing
for a lot of films back in the day
regardless to have a tie-in novel again
to have a comic book form of issue
miniseries which could be the set up for
the for the TV show you have everything
set of their line again it does we're
not saying we're not saying 20 episodes
Netflix and Hulu have allowed the doors
to open up for eight episodes something
basic and simple where every cell is in
a major loss no because again santa
clarita diet happened so now it's not
participant I wasn't shot on water it
doesn't might as well have floated but
you talk about routing all right Sasha
if you guys are going to say the biggest
ding against my show is that it's like
Boardwalk Empire that's fantastic I'll
walk into a pitch meeting be like
baseplates Tremaine meets Boardwalk
Empire but it's only in this one club
sort of like the club and Luke Cage I
will sell that show that show will be
successful that show's soundtrack will
be successful that show will have people
banging down the doors to be on it you
basically have Empire plus all these
other shows I want to watch that show I
hope somebody watching is like the
Cotton Club would be a great show to
bring back and all in all the Emmys
thank you very much are you right now
all around here I guess first off I
would never Bank my show on like what
the soundtrack is going to be that's the
only thing that you're really selling
your show on your he's going to have
good music and that's all that's going
to do
this is not MTV's assembler right and
actors are theories and stuff that
people need to watch it's great to have
good music in a series absolutely but
everything you've already said has
already been done and there is no
clamoring for Waterworld I'm sorry it is
poison in Hollywood that is my that is
my final words on it is poison and
that's why they didn't want to do it Big
Lebowski has the established fanbase
they've proven that the other Coen
Brothers films can already work as
spin-offs very well and everyone wants
to see more of the dude so high all
right goodbye and what do you think all
right well just to kind of going off the
premise for box-office disappointment
cuz some people like go Watchmen made
some money watching me 185 million
worldwide but off a production budget
130 million that's why kind of gets
pegged as the box office disappointment
the water world attraction Universal
Hollywood was closed for refurbishment
it's now open again so you can go see
the water world's not showing in this
hardwood George Clooney didn't write an
article he gave an interview to that I
was a little of an argument basically
drunkenness taquile basically there was
a a financier who was criticizing Sony
for flops and called out Waterworld as
an historic Quattro he basically saying
that was a bad pick for him they did
some research that said that now
nowadays projections it may have
actually grossed about 67 million
dollars that were made today so Chloe
was kind of criticizing someone else for
single out water world's a flop would a
because he was defending monuments men
or something he was he was it was going
to be shopping monuments men there's
basically a guy that was going after
Sony saying you put out these two flops
White House down and after earth and
he's like those are of those are
historic plots like Ishtar and water
world and Lady display6 thing like if
you're calling those flops and you don't
know anything about the business because
they weren't that much them yeah it's
the host but he didn't write the article
it was based up and interview came to
this I told you like a whole editorial
piece defending Waterworld would have
been great
some suggest as we got online that David
Wilson suggests David Lynch's dude Mac
cool suggested babies kids with the
Saturday morning animation and Robert
Moore says he would love to see a king
Arthur HBO series Game of Thrones it's
funny you mentioned dune the Cotton Club
actually earned less than doing his
opening weekend I actually
remember leaving do my parents not not a
goodness at all back again
all right based on these arguments it
was Roger for me because he really took
me down Sasha's explaining that it is
seeing it a lot he was really good at
point that and then yet when he pointed
out how predict ulis a budget of
Waterworld was and how we turn into a
global warming piece that's not what's
fun about Waterworld I think it's right
and whether no highly does or not I
think we have proven somehow that Coen
Brothers can somehow turn into good TV
shows so there is a possibility so I
think more the dude is makes the most
sense of these three Roger gets the
point
I lost the judge if I want to go I don't
know I watch is okay I actually like
Waterworld I 55 our fans like water I'll
to 55 percent of the of the online fans
voted for Waterworld three I do
36 percent the big without the only nine
percent it's funny of the the Cotton
Club Diane Lane was also in another flap
that year what was it I'm totally
blanking out Streets of Fire which is a
movie I love and that's another one I
would love to see turned because it was
originally supposed to be a trilogy and
she was amazing it in the name and the
attackers know yeah well anyway now
we're tied people will think I'm doing
that on purpose to keep the show
interesting but I'm not
that's just how surprising that we have
good fighters always get points around
for guys Daniel day-lewis is retiring
from acting what how sad is this where
we're lucky to have him
yeah it's crazy I guess it just doesn't
care anymore he's got three other
careers it's like I want to go do others
I mean just give it a key anymore just
wants to go to other stuff hey good for
him he can do whatever the hell he wants
right so let's go back and really talk
about what is the best Daniel day-lewis
performance there's so many
Roger were back to you which one you
pickin yeah I mean I've always loved
Daniel day-lewis he's an incredible
actor just the amount of work that he
puts into his craft I can understand why
he wants to retire it's probably just
exhausting for him just to put that much
of himself and he never leaves character
it's well known once he's once he's in
it and for that reason high pick there
will be blood it is basically there's
just no doubt that this is his most
incredible performance of an already
incredible career it's everything all
the years of perfecting his craft had
built up to that's what I really think
it is because he's he's gone through a
whole lot of movies I mean obviously he
splits them up but just when you think
about what movies he's been in and just
how much better he got over time it's
incredible
what this culminated with so I gotta go
with there will be blood and we'll
forget morons yes Sasha what are you
pickin I picked my left foot I mean
Roger you said he never leaves character
he played a man who had severe cerebral
palsy could only operate his left foot
and Daniel day-lewis was rumored to
although he eventually cleared up the
rumors have broken two ribs because what
he physically contorted himself into for
the character he would not get out of
the wheelchair he had crew members
carrying him on and off set and the crew
members would be like cursing him and
muttering but he wanted to feel the
humiliation that the real man he was
playing himself he was spoon-fed by crew
members on set never dropped character
that to me is such a depth of
performance that did more than just show
us great acting although it is
unbelievable acting it showed us a world
that we would never have experienced
otherwise so the whole story of my left
foot is this one man could only operate
his left foot Daniel day-lewis could
only really do his right foot so a lot
of movie a shot in a mirror and he
became an incredible writer an artist
and that's what Daniel day-lewis is and
I think that what she was able to do in
my left foot is sort of exemplary in
that he barely moves he barely does
anything he's not giving big speeches
he's not yelling he's not being
grandiose it's tiny it's so humane it's
so beautiful and it is one of the most
memorable performances I have ever seen
in my life not just in Daniel day-lewis
is exemplary career J uh both of those
are pretty damn good ones
just want to preface it and say that
ladies Dillman I had to go a little bit
different I went with the boxer if you
remember he played the story of a rising
teen boxer and a Belfast native Daniel M
Flynn who was arrested when he was young
and he was a he was good at what he did
and then once he got out of prison he
wanted to open up a gym started training
people in the neighborhood and again got
brought back in from all of the cohorts
he had me IRA
now again we say about the physicality
and the method acting of Daniel
day-lewis he trained physically
intensive as a boxer for over a year and
a half just in preparation before they
even had a script he trained so hard
that his trainer even said that Daniel
day-lewis could actually compete at the
professional middleweight level so to
have somebody who does that in that role
to do that is an exemplary thing again
just like what my left what I'll give
you that I definitely will but also in
this movie it is the third combination
between director Jim Sheridan and Daniel
day-lewis
when Sheridan was doing six different
films I believe in regards to the
situation in Ireland and it's a dramatic
film that takes you on a non-stop and it
motion roller coaster this movie
consistently goes from beginning to end
there is no stop of the there's not a
lagging moment in this film so that's
why pick the box so the thing about the
boxer because that is a great movie is
the round work that was laid with Jim
Sheridan the director of that started
with my left foot that was the first
movie they did together and I don't
think that had they had they not done my
left foot I don't know that they would
have had the discourse that they were
able to bring the boxer with and I loved
there will be blood but with there will
be blood you've got Paul Thomas Anderson
you've got paul dano you've got huge
scope you've got incredible spectacle
and yes if we were saying what may be
the most quoted Daniel day-lewis I would
say if there will be blood but some the
best I don't think it says that I think
in terms of him being that sort I was
like over bombastic character I would
gone with a butcher in terms of like
those four for talking about over
bombastic but he runs the gamut in this
film of emotions and stuff I mean there
are just little subtle just facial
twitches that when he's not even
speaking in the film that just kill you
and so it's an incredibly for a vast neo
film you know as far as visuals go it's
your experience with him is so intimate
it I dare say it's more
in any any other film he's ever been in
and I that's why I see not only is this
the best film of his career I honestly
think this is the best acting
performance period in the history of
film when you do this that's how much I
really think this when you go visually
with boxing and the fighting and the war
torn in the boxer that it shows you is a
lot especially the emotion with him and
Emily watching the up closest how they
put a project and convey all that
emotion when the camera is looking at
them to make you want to just almost cry
with them at times again for him to have
a long-lost love to reconnect with that
and in the midst of trying to reconnect
with that you have like I said Emily
Watson you have a general McSorely you
have all these people in this film that
bring you into this world they're you
most people never travel to Ireland most
people only hear the tales but you saw
it visually and again just like yes when
my left foot he did that but he also
does that with the boxer he also takes
you down this path takes you through
this road and this world consistently
rolls also it shows you that I'm as
potent as his performance with us
especially contained powerhouse it
showed me how Danny is a closed-off man
he's shadowboxing with private demons
you get to see all of that in Daniel
day-lewis again a method actor who wants
to take on everything who researches
this who wants to say how am I going to
play somebody who's dealing with my own
all right again best performing on let's
not get hung up on all the other things
around it we're all in agreement that
Daniel puts in a hell of a lot of work
for the film but it's the performance
that is on screen yes yes so you're
talking about intimates the intimacy in
there will be blood I in my left foot
you have so little to work with she
doesn't have his body to work with he
only really has a little bit of facial
expression and a little bit of his foot
he is hilariously funny he makes you
feel to the depths of your soul and
let's be honest he gets bombastic in the
film as well in order to get all that
there are many things that we don't
really want to look at on-screen and
severe cerebral palsy is one of those
things that you don't really want to
like dig into for two hours well and
that is a film that you want to watch
because of performance but you also want
to character you're going to live with
and you can connect like come on walking
got so short I know I don't notice
spirit yeah you Larry like what happens
a name okay I didn't conquer to me
literally he takes you for as far every
most any connecting oven character which
is why this is one of his it's not his
best and most powerful performance he
connects with you on so many levels
because again you're seeing all this
life and tragedy through the eyes of
this characters and things they lose you
showing everything they're not losing
everything trying to get everything back
your loan loss slow game very with
nothing what are you're born with
nothing and you have to build a life out
of that and that's what I think its own
don't say people don't want to see the
the cerebral palsy and stuff because 14
out of the last 27 Oscar wears have been
people playing roles where they've been
disabled I mean that's where
fact-checker absolutely do it either and
Eddie Redmayne it started with Oakland
Hoffman Rio in What's Eating Gilbert
Grape and outside of that but there's
but those are still prominent Washington
Post man you can look it up they did an
article about you still see him
able-bodied and then what but there's a
disintegration and you get to blood put
yourself into the empathic roars okay
I'm mad why is this performance the best
going around right back to the closings
around why why is your performance
stronger than my left foot happy to
explain it first off it's it's
practically a one-man show in this with
all the other great actors that are in
it's still all about Daniel Plainview
it's heartbreaking because this is just
much like his career it's showing the
culmination of everything he's worked up
to and this film has that gradual build
to it it starts off very intimate it's
just him in a mind and it feels
dangerous you know with him exploding
the dynamite he can hurt himself and all
that then the you have the other worker
who he's hired and he has to adopt his
son who gets damaged and it's so
heartbreaking because you see some
glimmers of joy in in plain view when
he's with HW actually see oh there's
like a little chance for happiness and
stuff but soon as he loses his hearing
it's like he abandons him it's this it's
just awful change of pace and he
basically denounces his son by the end
of a competitor and calling him a
bastard
in a basket it's it runs again of
emotion and I most of his other films
he's kind of there like the whole time
but this one it is it goes from
basically starting with his slow
obsession into obsession and greed and
loneliness and eventually he becomes
completely mad and I think it's because
of that wide range of emotions and that
intimate experience with the entire
thing sometimes he's scaring us to death
sometimes you don't know what he's going
to do sometimes you're feeling awful for
him it just runs every single emotion
you can experience when watching a film
and that's why I think compared to any
other thing he's ever done or any other
actor for that matter it is just an
amazing amazing perfect performance
Sascha closing thoughts so what you just
said is that was what he had worked up
to think about how young he was when he
did my left foot that was 20-plus years
before he would do there would be Berlin
probably 15 years before there was it's
like the beginning nations of his career
you were seeing raw talent the level of
complete immersion into character is
beyond anything because we can talk
about research and we can talk about him
woodworking or learning how to do
butchery but to contort your body into
ways that he had to be in physical
therapy for months afterward because
there were so much done to him and also
to truly tray of human experience that
we will never get to really know we can
look at it but that's what great cinema
does is it immerses you in something
that you would never ever be able to see
otherwise to see this man's journey
somebody who would otherwise probably
have been discarded somebody who has
never even considered like still won't
become anything and then there's one
moment in the film when the
eight-year-old version of his character
draws the word mother in chalk and you
realize that there is every opportunity
and every possibility in the fan and
then you see Daniel day-lewis play him
as an adult and what he does you want to
talk about a gambit of emotions I'm
talking about it now thinking back on it
and I'm getting chills because it is
heartbreaking it is uplifting it is
frightening it is everything that we
have come to expect from Daniel
day-lewis and it was basically when we
first got to know him talk about a hello
nice to meet you hi my name is that is
the best introduction I could possibly
think of and also his best performance
ever J closing thought
when you say the physical nature what he
did for my left foot again I take
nothing away from it but again you have
to go you put yourself in a physically
strenuous environment being a
professional boxer training to do that
just as much as I be hated for
professional wrestler hello quick look
hello quick look what he did that just
as well and also when you say the gamut
of emotion the character gaining flame
that he played he showed you everything
he showed you the emotion the heartbreak
the anger him having to become mature
throughout the film is maturity level
increased throughout the entire film as
we watch a person goes from being an
immature little kid to just reckless to
now trying to solidify themselves and
become somebody stable in an environment
and grow about that
what type of progressive is Academy and
where that's another claim perform
succeeding not Academy because my left
what he got back that is an acclaimed
performance to have within itself that
is one of those performances that go
under look and undervalued for four
months and I get out here I was just
doing some fact-checking Daniel is
cruising left acting for five years from
1997 2002 to become among other things a
shoemaker played everything Leonardo
DiCaprio was nominated for Gilbert Grape
is about supporting actor Roger I found
the article you were talking about the
Washington Post that was from 2015 they
had a very broad definition it was
facing significant civil war mental
barriers but this included like Anthony
Hopkins and slice of the Lambs and Jeff
Bridges and Nicolas Cage's alcoholics
and leaving Las Vegas and I think it's I
mean you can parse words I think it's a
very broad definition of how they
defined the challenges that they said to
those character space the last
physically disabled person that he had
made a ready-made walking in theory of
everything but we've had other actors
that were playing different kinds of
roles so Roger technically was true but
I you know that was a very broad range
the blood paint brush at that article
paid with so you know no writer on there
just a bit of a gray area and I have the
of course as always the viewer poll
whenever you ready look I'll say who
it's not do that either Beth Jay but I
think I got a lot
just a lot from Roger and Sasha there
and I'm torn this because they're really
different performances Dan what do you
think based on those arguments that this
one's rough I mean it's about the the
physical is what you focused on which is
a huge part of it but then but this is
the culmination of them yeah ii argues i
can i can argue the same thing well but
he's only even better after he's done
right work right the rock hammer
i mean it i also have a personal
favorite setting that aside you know i I
agree it's the two very completely
different kinds of performances so it's
very hard through the steps I'd like our
heroes right here's around O'Hare and
tell me if you where you're at but I
think I heard just there was just a
little bit more variety from Roger than
in the performance because I think they
are equally as good but in what you
talked about of what he does I mean yes
we can't ignore the physical and how
hard and brutal them up in that said you
really get so many more emotions of and
I'm seeing the obsession the madness
just the moments of joy to the facial
twitches to the everything there'll be
blood really does as even just said it's
the cultivation of all the years in one
place so I think I got to just give the
slight edge to Roger and narrow the
glasses down a mile but so not to be
discredit I mean what a role not a bit
I'm not sure is great to have the sort
of uh not not sure I do better okay when
I send a lot like at noon here this
winter trout gave more than an edge
though we've got 70% doubting for that
18 percent my left foot 12 percent for
the boxer all great performances yeah
it's gonna be yeah I'm also glad he's
finishing his final film with flame LM
yeah yeah so I'm very excited about that
I saw my left foot I was like ah crazy
there you know as you can retire for 10
years whatever and then I won they'll do
one like old role and it's going to be
amazing I just don't want another day in
the movie I
and like I want to smush that maybe bad
boy so boring are you oh my god look
beautiful action beautiful and they
didn't care oh I'm sorry I heard the
play sorry immersion I got the player
played I started reading his rich
history is too boring they could have
been Bill Bergey now he could have done
a little better way big Dan with real
quick with level 2 school but I'm sorry
our nation's real high get me it was a
well made movie added some currency
that's enough don't even I mean well we
meet bill to my house for Lincoln they
lived like an age and time appropriate
house in about a full movie but then I
heard he still checked his email around
true that it all right round five this
guy's 25th anniversary of Batman return
yeah so that man asked wonder what is
the best film of 1992
you could pick Batman Returns you could
pick all the other there's a lot of good
movies in a line of you not show what
you picking a picture Reservoir Dogs
oh come on I just want to do a slow-mo
walk with all of you guys in black suits
and white Jerry super squeeze now oh
we're talking about community no coming
out the gates her make a deal
unbelievable Michael Madsen is changing
independent cinema for all time
soundtrack snap it is the over to
penguin oh my god about the lines there
so much Johnna mono long if I start like
a virgin it's just nothing yet and
there's actors like that I think
gotcha just wants to watch oh listen I
will be all about loop I just love about
mr. pink colors has never been more
meaningful that change he didn't say
don't like what we kind of started
getting Sundance and Sex Lies and
videotapes would totally blown open and
it's all these things we love though
clicking Tarantino
it's such hyper violent if crazy vulgar
its nonlinear storytelling which nobody
was doing it change the whole damn game
alright ah great
oh it's so good ok ok do you like that
movie I love it ok I just don't know how
I could match the level of energy with
my movie I paid that's the only problem
I think in my ears please don't I left
us
I actually went different I was I
there's a lot of movies in 92 if you
look down the list and I had to remember
some other scene and one of the ones
that stuck out the most is one that
still when it comes on to this day
people will tune in to it they want to
watch it it's a few good men Tom Cruise
Jack Nicholson Demi Moore the story of a
marine who was charged with killings
were charged with killing a fellow
marine and in the lawyer brings in a
Marine Colonel to try to uncover all the
conspiracy that is going on you this
movie was directed by Rob Reiner ok also
had Kiefer Sutherland Kevin [ __ ]
written by Aaron Sorkin which if you
have anybody knows you know Aaron Sorkin
films you have to stay to the threat
that he writes he hates that
so they have actors who want to kind of
deviate from what they do and try to
have their own flair to it to have to
take Tom Cruise to take what was
maverick and make him this straight less
because never Top Gun and turn him into
this guy oh you know what he was in here
my brain something others what it take
time crews nonetheless and it keeps him
straight on the point where he needs to
be or with this is a great thing to have
him and Rob Reiner be on the same Accord
to deliver this to have an astounding
actor as Jack Nicholson to play this
stubborn just gritty Lieutenant Colonel
who just is like i'ma stay as hard as I
can to this and again we saw and still
to this day have the most accurate quote
from that film that everybody uses you
want the truth you can't handle the
truth and I'll say the rest later okay
I'm glad we got that light out I knew is
go ahead and at some point of course it
has
of course that's one of the most quoted
problems yeah it is
for me it is Batman Returns absolutely I
do think that is the best film of 1992
and it was a fantastic year but Batman
Returns that is the it's such a good
superhero film I actually liked it way
more than the original Tim Burton Batman
and the reason why is basically they
tried to be different from any other
superhero film that existed at the time
it scared Warner so much that they made
Batman Forever and stuff because they
say was it went so dark and that's a
risky thing to do with the kissing and I
love that Tim Burton was like you know
what all right I'm going to come back I
will do a sequel but I'm going to do it
my way and that's why this movie is so
good because it is pure Tim Burton it is
all the wacky carnival folks that he
brings in there it is Tim Burton at his
best at the height of his powers and I
absolutely loved what they did I mean
just some of the characters that we got
out of it we got the greatest Catwoman
in history with Michelle Pfeiffer I mean
come on yes I I know I know the old the
classic Adam West the air the Kings I
remember it I was good no no no ah look
ah but Michelle Pfeiffer
she made it something way better and I
mean not only was she is seductive femme
fatale but she also had this tragic
story so you feel you feel for her and I
may not be a real man yet but if I am I
became a man when I saw Michelle
Pfeiffer his Catwoman and I think a lot
of other people did too and we'll get
into some of the other characters in a
bit all right find it out guys that's
the night - we gotta go straight to your
mind about Tom Cruise being
straight-laced and like sticking to the
script Tom Cruise loved sticking to a
script that's his favorite thing yes
that is mine I don't think too hard
Kevin what to deviate he is king of
straight-laced so he was to give you an
Aaron Sorkin strict makes perfect sense
and thank you for doing that one line
that we needed because the rest of the
movie is good but like what you really
loved that Kevin Bacon part you were
saying people always watch it when it
comes on TV and stuff people will be
like where is it in the movie oh it's
not at the end all right I'm going to go
watch something else they will turn back
to it just to see that one ladder
interact
in between and the question initially is
what is the best movie of 1990 two out
of the three in which we made some bad
net returns again it has so if they have
a bunch of flaws I do
Christopher Walken is next right if I do
it amazing oh my god I don't think we're
walking in that the beautiful
Christopher Walken noticing that because
he was just Christopher Walken in that
movie we can all agree with that okay
come on
he was here mr. Berger you hate him in
that bad and the bad man is super dark
in this movie again we had no doubt is
that where we're going with this Batman
murders people in this yet okay some
people have a problem with the current
Batman doing it he stuffs a bomb into a
giant rubber guy found throws him down
and that carnival guy that is the guy
who plays both early and over-the-top
you guys should know that now when it
comes to Reservoir Dogs a geek yes it
gave us our introduction into the menus
and it was the very first one I don't
think it was I'm not mistaken I don't
care anything if you believe what I
bring no one did you set for class you
say first Quentin Tarantino that's what
I heard you say I did we want to take
whatever I say about that not saying
nothing bad about it at all but I'm just
saying it's not the best movie in 1992 I
guess growls oh this is what makes bad
man I mean not bad man returns a few
good men because how many awards were
either one of the movies that you to
write brought up nominated for now you
had this movie which was the where
Lawrence matter and is a battle a fun
question is not in the list of these
three smells we're talking about the
color you're losing more defendant what
your fight is the movie in which you
brought up again you have you have a few
good men which was the winner of the
people show us a war for Iowa one
sadly a few the man was also the critics
choice at the local town raffle I just
want you guys to know that as well yeah
very very more not about what you're
saying about Tim Burton looks like I'm
going to come back well so I love Tim
Burton his best
Tim Burton vest is Edward Scissorhands
Tim Burton on now I apologize but when
you talk about cinema right we're
talking about movies and the best movie
of the year the best in a year for me is
a movie that will actually change the
way people go to the movies the moment
where Michael Madsen starts curving
a cop's ear off and the camera pans up
although a lot of people don't remember
that a lot of people think that you
actually see him cut the ear off people
got sick and stormed out of the theater
and that was because of the implication
of what they thought they were seeing
that they weren't even seeing you have
Tim Roth you have Harvey Keitel you have
Michael Madsen in career-defining
performances brought to you by a guy who
would like written a script for true
romance
nobody's obviously promised great moving
in a great movie but no one saw this
film coming and you cannot tell me but
most of the films that we would see now
would be as they are if we hadn't had
this incredible film because you have
poetic vulgarity you have such intense
violence and you have criminals that
you're rooting for when you talk about
fancy heroes but none of the superhero
movies that we see today you would have
because back then you didn't know that
if a bad guy shot another bad guy or a
bad guy was maybe a good guy you never
knew everything was clearly defined in
Quentin Tarantino took all those
definitions and created new one actually
Batman Returns it wasn't clearly defined
because Catwoman was kind of like
bouncing between the toes you're not
really sure about a custom in you and
I'm a preview interjected just so you
all want to act like I am here but you
have a few good men whereas one of those
who is something you like to end because
I know what you're holding I know you
too well but I know that that beard is
jumping a little bit just be okay there
with you I said but I enjoy my time but
when it comes to a few good men it is it
straight-laced courtroom drama set in
the mill in the military setting how are
you had that fan base that loves that it
gives you what it won that granted the
main thing that again the you want the
truth you can't handle truth was giving
away in the trailer but again you led up
to it you led up to it you anticipating
you
it was a movie that kept me on it kept
you gripped into it I probably get into
the in the best thing about a few good
men is the thing that Batman Returns is
missing and that is Jack Nicholson no
good then that was what goes better
because the dynamic grammar and modern
society was good but he's not as good as
a villain you don't make good as a
villain he goes up against in the
penguin and not a great villain oh then
now that was I definitely dig it you
with that they actually tase you know
who they they made the penguin honking
credible in this movie and by the way
you want to talk about Paul Reubens you
told me on Twitter Paul Reubens pee-wee
Herman was his father any problems yeah
yeah and any time you shall he did yes
but when you're talking about a movie
Reservoir Dogs yeah of course it's quick
Tarantino he's got to do things that are
unconventional and it was never done
before this is that's the problem with
Reservoir Dogs is it doesn't hold up as
well now it really doesn't it does like
if you give me a bill holy God citizen
that is a number one record of feels
like film school it really does and pulp
fiction feels like the graduation this
is him after films well he's getting out
it's not as flawed as Reservoir Dogs I'm
sorry Reservoir Dogs feels like film
school it's because everything that
we've learned now about how to make
great movies came from that movie and
it's been studied and defected and
beloved for so long that people are like
oh this is how to make a great thing and
that's what would make it film school or
what and why why did that memory turn is
better than film school already very
well let's see besides it being
incredibly dark we're getting not one
grade bill we're getting three great
villains Max Schreck Christopher Walken
is excellent as the business tycoon in
it
Michelle Pfeiffer as Catwoman I mean
just incorrect that was a
career-defining one for and after she
had already been in fantastic roles
Danny DeVito as the penguin this was a
role that I mean on paper you would not
think that the penguin would be just
like some great villain in a movie but
Tim Burton actually made him dark he
made you actually feel a little bad for
him at first and you know with the the
tragic story of his parents then he
turns evil then he he gets more twisted
with running for the mayor and
everything whether it's devouring raw
fish murdering a circus performer or
running for mayor with all the wrong
intentions you can't help but
every minute of screen time and think
about how dark they really got with this
like by the end all right when the dark
and three villain yeah anymore what did
that's all you keep saying oh I mean
yeah it's a great Christmas movie okay
all right I'm just trying to cut some
chase oh sure okay it's there to be
different and I think that's it I think
that really just sets the stage for a
lot of superhero films what they said
was the best thing of Batman that's why
he was in final it sounds awesome
you know what the filling for the Batman
whistle why you have a villain in Dan
well you got oh boy how's the movies
didn't make this list
Aladdin Unforgiven the last Mohicans
Wayne's World going Gary Ginn reforms
was my second room out the bag was a
player instead of a woman by lieutenant
my cousin's any stop for my mom will
shoot plastic one Roger surprised
couldn't Vinny I just watching that's a
really good Mike Rogers memorize you
didn't counter Jays People's Choice
Awards with the fact that that and I
heard was nominee for Kids Choice away I
said oh no no that means Jay you are
you're misquoting that movie slightly I
want the truth and that you can't handle
the truth is the actual quote from a few
could bed because and then the only
thing you need to learn from Anders you
can yeah anyway and then yeah Sasha I
think some fans of the movie City on
fire might argue that Reservoir Dogs is
the best movie in 1987 but that's a
whole other movie no one said that that
is the whole lot of movie fight exactly
as waiting for someone to say that not
in that Depp has a noncombatant I was
sitting here is my heart okay well sorry
so here's where I'm stuck because I the
argument get through Good Men was pretty
solid it's a great scene yes my whole
point
and then BAM around the I was rude we're
trying to get barriers but you just you
really just did repeat the Catwoman's
great Catwoman's great really dark it's
really dark got three good willing you
know is just trying to get more out of
you and I didn't I just couldn't hear
Reservoir Dogs can't believe because I
know
heroes of our down gone down I didn't
hear anything else against and you did
really give me about the fact that we
just changed the way the movies where it
did whether it ripped it off or not it
doesn't matter it did and it's really
just watchable and quotable and all the
things you said so I got to give it to
Sasha on that one arguing no one just
starting to try and J anyway something
I'm and I want to congratulate fifty
three percent of people voted for Rhodes
warthogs 24-hour basically a tie between
a few admitted and returns 24 to 20
creepers well do you be men with my
background I must say if you could men
is a fantastic really good film ill it's
a few good seen it's many good things
being an accident and that see misra
mazing it is really it is I think even
if we're runners-up ever it says his dog
all right here we go you guys ready for
this ah around here and Roger and Sasha
unless employ a man helping love cake
don't know I'm not I'm not holding a way
to do that will let you them in anyone
hear the music here we go in here the
music theater and music we go okay only
someone hears is this alright guy you're
lots of things number one the voices who
should play carnage to Tom Hardy's venom
damn ten seconds
pretty broad come on just yeah dance
this guy's bringing his own hands got an
answer to one really I got one no one
got it oh what's that
there's no answer they're not playing I
know but I didn't turn it no one alright
so that doesn't count
alright so like that well nobody is the
point that means just have four question
how do we establish the rule on that I
don't think we read no one answer yeah
you guys are tied so we'll see how that
goes alright so yeah question five I
guess is a wash here we go number two
any answer literally when I hit should
anybody up here alright let's try and
just name let's try and give answers not
angry well in honor of the 20th
anniversary a face-off
who would you rather swap faces with
Travolta or Nicolas Cage like oh hold on
well no so you got yours you gotta
imagine I have a question yes is it
maybe I particular era no stay on now or
is it battle career okay Tim the person
and we're going to make its face oh all
right Roger you got Cage go ahead when
you're ready I would much rather have
cage than Travolta because I feel like
it looks like Travolta has already
switched his faces with a lot of people
it kind of looks like it's been a little
bit worn out at this time and cage cage
just has such an expressive face whether
he's making his eyes really wide or just
going crazy he can do so much more with
his face and I like that I want to be
able to entertain people with it so okay
Sasha if I expressive you mean look like
a psycho person yes you should have
Paige's face but Travolta has those
dreamy blue eyed the Vinnie Barbarino
beautiful mask you've got that lustrous
fake hair but still is hanging in there
you've got that dimpled chin and
everybody just wants to like stick a
tongue in it lick you've got those
cheeks that were the thing that made
face off so good it's a man of evil it's
a man of good it's a dancing face
okay this is my turn yes he's got those
he's got those dreamy eyes yeah the same
dream you guys that make every actress
who has to go on stage with a man an
award show feel really uncomfortable no
I don't want that I want the ladies to
love me and they love Nicolas Cage Paul
no ladies would understand anything
John Travolta is a man from Saturday
Night Fever all the way through to face
off up through get Shorty and to the
People vs of decency where the face is
good all right okay Manson those
arguments what are you taking her a fan
poll about women would rather love with
an at-home winner ooh sure bolta hands
effort rolls at cage
it depends one area Hey no he has that
for Travolta head no and replicate all
right Jason higher education argument I
would do cage sasha broke every part of
John Travolta face that she was the
temple would see me I so I've got to go
with I gotta go with sauces because of
the way she broke down everything on
this one all right we dancing those
arguments I have to agree the question
was whose fates would you ever have it's
not a road now John Cyril to face Jeff I
feature in like you want to happen I
have to say to see answer the question
thorough hearted in a Mac I hope I hope
not only does she win this meter but you
get to have John Trumbull yeah gonna
work I might have tag dancing face
alright here we go
oh c'mon dimples in it yeah oh boy okay
should always change before I go okay
this is always good in honor of the 30th
anniversary of Spaceballs best Mel
Brooks movie oh my god mmm
Spaceballs Oh
Young Frankenstein oh thank god all
right yeah there's a lot to pick from
yeah all right Roger you're first what
he planned starts to begin speaking okay
Spaceballs is pretty much the parody
that everyone didn't know they needed
and it was so good it takes the best
things out of every Star Wars film and
turns it around on its head and it not
only makes fun of Star Wars it makes fun
of aliens you with the classic alien
Burt chestburster scene it's just
perfect comedy and it is Mel Brooks that
is this when you talk about the comedy
you have to talk about Gene Wilder not a
link on and this is probably their two
best performances and that is saying a
lot considering the careers that both of
them had Mel Brooks took a shara that
people didn't want to see anymore and
made it original again he brought comedy
to a different level and black and white
actually worked in a way that it rarely
does because of what he was able to do
in terms of making it a parody making an
ironic 10 seconds when you're ready
Roger okay no one was ever really
clamoring for a sequel to Young
Frankenstein but everyone wanted a
sequel for Spaceballs and it Rick
Moranis was amazing in this movie talk
about defining you know just like you're
talking about Gene Wilder he's
incredible in you're talking about
something that I already had franchise
going into it people expected a sequel
to Spaceballs cancerverse people to Star
Wars but the thing about young brain
Stein is that it is beyond brilliant and
so original you don't need a sequel when
you have to move that'll really Dan
coming to you first and his argument I
think that Roger to me you just told me
what Spaceballs was which was that it
was the Star Wars parody and I think
that Sasha's really got down here at
ringside was and why it was so great no
I have to go Sasha okay I'm the exact
same way are
believe we're all not so broke
everything Jenna you got me to study how
you got weighed in nitty-gritty of it
and all right ready Travolta Roger needs
this point to tie when L read Roger
needs both of these they got to point no
pressure
all right and honour of war the Planet
of the Apes what is the best motion
capture performance of all time Gollum I
want to play poker all I want to do
right now is I'm not limping that I want
to say I'm not going to say it we'd best
motion capture of all time the best
motion capture of all time it isn't
Gollum as the best wrestler of all time
is going to be either but I keep wanting
to say pole no it's either it's either
dancer season rich movie I dawn it's on
user and dawn okay that's a fair fight
I'd say these are gonna daily fame after
first air again hey guys all right Roger
here first
Gollum really showed people what that
kind of acting can be it took it to a
new level it just changed everything I
mean with already amazing performances
in this movie
everyone was absolutely mesmerized by
Gotham and it's Forest Friends girl from
happy and stomach you see he's two
people so he's not the fact that you can
recreate that voice here says it's not a
special I'm gonna take your PT Anderson
things throw it back in your face
everything you learned on the Lord of
the Rings is what he uses in Dona Planet
of the Apes and that's what makes that
performance so incredible because your
fans are prioritizing an animal and
making it more human than a regular
human actor could possibly do Andy
Serkis is the master of all this but
Caesar is his crowning achievement just
ba
Caesar is not his crowning achievement
because everyone was talking about gum
you don't see people talking about
Caesar constantly that was not it Gollum
everyone wanted to be Gollum I wanted to
become that's why I learned to speak
like him he created it which is it's not
a special it's not special is taking
animals showing with his violence is
inhumanity is rage
sensitivity that is suitable to do with
just a few little dot on her face who
Jing based on those arguments where you
leaning all right
I love golem off the voice and a lot of
people think about the voice of golem
but the way Sasha's argument is to bring
down the emotions up from the anger the
rage the different phases there
everything he brought to it I'm going to
with Cesar I'm going with awesome damn
yeah this was a little tougher but I
think the two arguments were dollar was
popular but Cesar was better and I think
I side with the Cesar side of the
argument so I would go through comes
down to me thank you for the advice
there but yeah you did something
interesting man you took the chance
needs a little bit did the line and then
when she sort of look through it back at
you saying well so you can even just do
it I did like that that punch but I also
think you yeah you got the popularity
contest it was you should have given me
there's so much more he does the guys
think he did he's Inc with more time
everybody was telling me and III would
had a shot there but Sasha I got a few
more points out as to why that
performance is so nuanced in missile
mattress so much happens I got to get
fashion a point that means
[Applause]
and you we got to hang sensory killer
and I guess and hang out with Andy
Serkis
and honest interviews in which case
would be long soon he raped my column
impression and I'm very bad I wish I
love it
not really good but whatever business
but I'd like to thank you guys are a
wonderful fight here today let's go
through and make sure we get your plugs
on here
Roger bar what a great good welcome back
so they do have eight nine eight months
back thank you finds you an ayah mockery
on Twitter anything else you'd like to
tell them too young IMO cker why on
Twitter and Instagram you can go to my
website I'm also going to be at
comic-con in July I will have a booth in
row six hundred and both number II ten
come to see my new game it's called
grave chase it's a Halloween game where
you get to play as these kids taking
upgrades and everything it's going to be
on Steam this fall if you go to Steam
right now you can actually add it to
your wish list and everything cuz it's
all ready to go so you're going to check
out great check it out crazy a for the
first time I want to do it I love it
Sasha pearl raver at Apple raver yeah
you can find me on Twitter and Instagram
and usually on screen junkies news but I
will be gone next week I'm gone vacay
every download rule Barbados dog very
excited FX review download this Friday
is going to be Days of Future past and
it's a really cool episode so cool love
it it's Popeye
Congrats on the win crusted Knight also
question today man you can't prepare to
love it you guys just please find wrong
keys just got Tolley wonderful it is Jay
Washington where would you like to send
our fan mr. Jay Washington on Twitter
and Instagram
definitely I'll be back will screen
junkies news soon Oakley and I also
catch the Troitsky psychic podcast on
itunes yeah you're great man thanks for
signing battling you so yeah good three
good fighters Dan Merrill and Merle Dan
good job I know and I'm alright but it
isn't the same without you can all go
back good glad why a show we're still
like the old days hello - OH yep it did
feel like the old days there we go
will awesome take you off for watching
we will be here next week same time same
place have a great one guys
[Music]